NCBI virus contains many sequences of
viral genomes that you can search to
start your search you can go to search
by virus once you click on search by
virus you can just type in the virus
that you would like to research for
example we can use current lines give it
just a few seconds and you'll see the
list of corona viruses appear down here
let's select severe acute respiratory
syndrome related corona virus or severe
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
which is the novel coronavirus that's
causing coded 19 as you can see there
are over 6,000 nucleotide sequences
available in this list not all of them
are full genomes and they come from a
variety of different locations and they
were collected or released at different
dates if we want to limit this number we
can first select sequence length or
nucleotide completeness we know that the
corona virus is about twenty eight
twenty nine thousand nucleotides long so
we can either select the complete or we
can give it a minimum in the maximum
length right here after we filter for
only complete nucleotide sequences you
will see that there is just four
thousand nucleotide sequences available
you can also go to geographic region and
for example just select all of those
that are in the US
there are over 2,800 nucleotide
sequences in the US alone if you scroll
through the different available metadata
you will see that each one has an
accession number if you click on the
accession number you can read more about
where this novel coronavirus was
collected from which host and USA
California you can also see when it was
submitted collection date length etc you
can also click on the bio project to see
how this whole sequence was submitted
Sarris your v2 genome sequences from
de-identified patient specimens
submitted for testing and quest
Diagnostics now let's say we want to
download a number of these sequences and
let's say what we want to do is take a
few from California a few from New
Jersey
whew from Utah
you from Kentucky
now that we've selected a number of
these sequences we can just simply
download them as fast the format genomic
sequence so here you can look at
nucleotide coding region protein this is
to download the FASTA format you can
also just download the accession list
number which will give you 12 accession
id's and download all the data in a CSV
or XML format click on next and just
download selected records inside the
FASTA file there's going to be a
beginning string that will contain the
accession number and all the information
that we just saw accession number or
accession in GenBank title
you can see that you can download all of
the sequence and now we can open it in
any text editor and we'll see if you do
a quick search you'll see how many
sequences you downloaded in this case we
downloaded 12 now you can use these
sequences to start your pipeline